>> Laura: THIS IS REALLY COOL.
IT'S A SPECIAL TUESDAY EDITION
OF OUR "SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT
WHERE WE EXPOSE THE CULTURAL
STORIES OF THE DAY.
BALTIMORE MISTREATS THE FIRST
LADY, JOINING US WITH ALL THE
DETAILS, RAYMOND ARROYO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
THE PRESIDENT SPENT SOME QUALITY
TIME WITH A FEW FEATHERED
FRIENDS AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT PELOSI AND SCHIFF.
>> TODAY WAS THE ANNUAL
PRESIDENTIAL TURKEY PARDON.
TWO BIRDS WERE FLOWN INTO D.C.
BY THE NATIONAL TURKEY
FEDERATION AND THEY WERE PUT UP
AT THE WILLARD HOTEL -- WHEN YOU
LOVE TO BE THE MAID CLEANING UP
THAT ROOM?
ONCE AGAIN THE WHITE HOUSE
POSTED STATS ON THE TWO TURKEYS
AND ALLOWED THE PUBLIC TO DECIDE
WHICH BIRD SHOULD GET THE
PARDON?
BEFORE THE BIG UNVEILED, THE
PRESIDENT USED THE OCCASION TO
PLUCK HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
>> BREAD AND BUTTER HAVE BEEN
SPECIALLY RAISED BY THE JACKSONS
TO REMAIN CALM UNDER ANY
CONDITION WHICH WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED SUBPOENAS TO
APPEAR IN ADAM SCHIFF'S BASEMENT
ON THURSDAY.
UNLIKE PREVIOUS WITNESSES YOU
AND I HAVE ACTUALLY MET.
>> THIS IS HIS GREAT WEAPON
POLITICALLY, HIS SENSE OF HUMOR.
NO ONE CAN ANSWER, YOU DON'T
HAVE ANYONE IN THE OPPOSING
PARTY WHO CAN MOUNT THAT KIND
OF -- MEET HIM ON A LEVEL OF
HUMOR AND CONNECT WITH THE
AUDIENCE.
IN THE PRESIDENT GOT TO BUSINES
BUSINESS.
>> BUTTER, LET'S TALK TO YOU FOR
A SECOND BECAUSE I'M GOING TO DO
SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING TO BE
VERY HAPPY ABOUT.
I WISH YOU A LOT OF LUCK, I
HEREBY GRANT YOU A FULL AND
COMPLETE PARDON.
>> THAT'S BUTTER, WHAT HAPPENED
TO BREAD?
I THINK THEY FED HIM TO
JERROLD NADLER TO TRY TO KEEP
HIM AT BAY OR MAYBE COHEN AND
THE ANTITERRORISM DOG HAD A
THANKSGIVING TREAT.
>> Laura: TO THE OTHER TURKEY
NOT GET PARDON?
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
>> IT WASN'T THERE, THE OTHER
ONE WAS NOT THERE.
IT COULD BE GRILLING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE KITCHEN AS WE SPEAK.
>> Laura: TOMMY JUST SAID HE'S
A BACKUP.
>> WE'VE GOT TO GET GOING, THIS
IS IMPORTANT STUFF.
I GOT TO TELL YOU ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Laura: HE HAD A HEART SCARE
IN OCTOBER, HE'S BEING CAREFUL
NOT EXERTING HIMSELF.
>> NOW HE IS SHOWING VOTERS IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE THAT HE STILL GOT
THE STUFF.
THE 78-YEAR-OLD SOCIALIST BECAME
THE DANCING KING THE OTHER NIGHT
AT THE LABOR SOLIDARITY DINNER
IN MANCHESTER.
AT LEAST THEY HAD FAIR WARNING.
>> OUR REVOLUTION INCLUDES
DANCING.
>> WHEN IT STARTED PLAYING, THE
REVOLUTION BEGAN, HE DID THE
CHA-CHA WITH A SERIES OF
SUPPORTERS AND LATER HE TWEETED
OUT HE WAS HAVING THE TIME OF
HIS LIFE.
SINCE THESE POLL NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN ERODING IN SOME PLACES AND
THE OBAMA MACHINE IS NOW AGAINST
HIM, HE MIGHT HAVE BETTER
PROSPECTS OVER AT "DANCING WITH
THE STARS."
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK YOU
WOULD GET ALL THE OPPOSITION
THAT POOR SEAN SPICER GOD?
GOD?
.I THINK HE'S A GOOD DANCER, I
THOUGHT HE WAS VERY GOOD ON HIS
FEET, THAT WAS THE BEST THING
I'VE SEEN HIM DO EVER.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE?
>> I HAVE TO SHOW YOU THE MOST
EMBARRASSING VIDEO OF THE DAY,
EMBARRASSING FOR BALTIMORE.
TODAY, 2500 HIGH SCHOOL AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS IN BALTIMORE
ATTENDED A YOUTH SUMMIT ON
OPIOID ADDICTION AND THE FIRST
LADY AND TENDED TO TALK TO THEM
ABOUT THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC, SHE
WAS GREETED THIS WAY.
>> THE FIRST LADY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
[BOOS]
>> HELLO EVERYONE.
>> Laura: LET ME SAY THIS,
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO ILL-INFORME
ILL-INFORMED, I'M GOING TO PUT
IT KINDLY ON THIS HOLIDAY SEASON
AND THEY ARE SO ANGRY OR THEY
ARE JUST SO BRAINWASHED,
WHATEVER THE TOP LINE IS THEY
READ ON FACEBOOK THAT THEY DON'T
REALIZE THEY'RE ACTUALLY HELPING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE FIRST
LADY BY THEIR UNGRACIOUS
REACTION.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THEM, DON'T
VOTE FOR HIM.
>> THESE ARE SCHOOL KIDS,
SOMEBODY IS PROMPTING, SOMEBODY
IS TEACHING THEM THAT IT'S OKAY
TO GO OUT AND HARASSED THE FIRST
LADY THIS WAY, I'M SORRY.
I WOULD HAVE OPPOSED THIS IF
THEY DID IT TO MICHELLE OBAMA OR
LAURA BUSH OR ANY FIRST LADY,
YOU WANT TO PROTEST THE
PRESIDENT?
HAVE AT IT.
TWO
TOO
TO -- HE IS THERE TO HELP YOU IN
THE MIDDLE OF AN OPIOID
EPIDEMIC.
>> EVOLVE AND BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
IF WE CONTINUE TO WORK
HAND-IN-HAND, I KNOW WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE AMAZING THINGS.
I'M FIGHTING FOR YOU.
>> Laura: I WANT TO SAY, GOOD
FOR HER, SHE SHOULD DO MORE
INTERVIEWS AND APPEARANCES,
EVERY TIME SHE DOES SHE DOES SO
WITH GRACE AND BEAUTY AND THIS
WAS A WONDERFUL AND NEEDED TO
MESSAGE.
SHE SHOWS THE COUNTRY WHAT REAL
CLASS IS, SHE SHOULD DO MORE
INTERVIEWS AND NOT IN ANY WAY
RETREAT BECAUSE OF UNGRACIOUS --
NOT THAT SHE WOULD BUT WHERE IS
PRINCIPAL, OR AS AN ADULT SAYING
GET ON STAGE SAYING ANYONE
BOOING, GET OUT.
>> THE PRINCIPAL NEEDS TO BE
TAUGHT MANNERS AND PASS IT ONTO
THEIR STUDENTS, IT WAS OF
NOXIOUS AND HORRIBLE.
>> Laura: I SEE THE GENTLEMAN
ON STAGE BEFORE THE FIRST LADY,
HE SEEMED PRETTY CASUALLY
DRESSED, THERE WAS A DAY PEOPLE
WOULD PUT ON A JACKET.
>> THAT WAS MARK WAHLBERG'S
BROTHER.
>> Laura: I'M GLAD HE'S THERE.
I'M GLAD HE WAS THERE AND DID A
NICE INTRODUCTION BUT HE'S
PRETTY COOL, GET UP THERE AND
SAY KNOCK IT OFF.
HAVE A GREAT THANKSGIVING AND
WE'LL SEE YOU ON FRIDAY FOR